[Music]
good evening I'm Stuart brand from the
long now foundation well a person I
spent a lot of time paying attention to
is Gregory Bateson and his wife Margaret
Mead I knew Gregory better back in the
1930s when they had been infected by
what was brand-new cybernetic theory the
idea of feedback they went to Bali in as
Steven Lansing was just telling me they
invented visual anthropology and did a
book called a Balinese character which
is a classic and is still studied by
everybody in business that was a nice
case of field anthropologists being set
in a different direction
by a very good body of theory which in
that case was cybernetics well the great
now maybe the grandchild of cybernetics
is complex adaptive systems complexity
theory as it's been manifest at Santa Fe
Institute where Steven Lansing is a
research research professor and I've
been on their board for 14 years or
something that's where I first saw a
version of this talk not nearly as
gorgeous as the one you'll see tonight
and Stevens a nice case of taking a new
body of theory how complex systems work
emergent behaviors the kinds of things
you can do with agent-based modeling and
bringing that to bear on one of the most
mysterious and wonderful bodies of of
behavior in in Bali and so in jazz
you'll see tonight he is also bringing a
new level of visual anthropology Steven
Lansing
thanks very much sir that's very
gracious and I need to apologize to all
you for turning up a week late I think
when I should have zagged a while back
in a ski land Wyoming so on a great
we'll be here now and actually I've been
downloading and listening to some of the
earlier talks in this series it's really
a very interesting series so I'm honored
to have an opportunity to try and join
this conversation I'm gonna take you in
a different direction and actually I'll
wind up talking about the long now but
rather than the physics of time in the
future I'm gonna take you down the kind
of wandering paths that ecologists and
anthropologists take and we'll wind up
in the end I hope with something to say
about about time and about the long now
so this is mostly about Bali so off to
Indonesia which has the highest
biodiversity on earth in terrestrial
ecosystems in the forests and also in
the oceans in the coral reefs but things
are not well in the in the tropics less
than the third of the coral reefs are
still healthy
most of the Borneo and the Sumatran
rainforests have been logged and
Indonesia is once again importing rice
so we are losing some of the most
precious treasures of the planet the
crown jewels question is why and part of
that has to do with politics certainly
but I think it also I hope to convince
you did have something to do with some
weaknesses in our science and how we see
the world so one of the things that
began with the era of 5-year plans in
the 60s not just an Indonesia but all
over the world wherever the World Bank
got busy was the implementation of
hierarchical control systems but but
anthropologists asked how did they
manage before they had five-year plans
right that you manage reproduced system
so question is don't complex ecosystems
like rice paddies require a firm
hierarchical control well maybe not
maybe there are different lessons about
how to organize the world so what I'll
talk about tonight is partly about the
sciences of complexities or the Santa Fe
Institute story with reference to
Balinese rice paddies but I want to talk
a little bit also about Lisa Kern's work
on the rainforests of Borneo and coral
reefs and in the end something about
time
so begin with complexity 1995 the great
biologist John Maynard Smith wrote in
the New York Review of Books that he has
a general feeling of unease when
contemplating complex systems dynamics
is after a week in Santa Fe its devotees
are practicing fact free science fact
for them is at best the outcome of a
computer simulation rarely a fact about
the world so these ideas that we talked
about in Santa Fe are new and unfamiliar
so one can ask if these processes were
really at work in the world would we
recognize them so I'm gonna give you the
quickest on definition of what a complex
adaptive system might be this is from
john holland one of the architects of
this notion of complexity so a complex
adaptive system is a network of
interacting agents in which they're
trying to maximize something and what he
discovered is that the aggregate
behavior of the network that is formed
by their interactions may be described
without a detailed knowledge of
individual agent behavior so there can
be emergent properties so that's a nice
and very general theoretical idea but
what I hope I can show you the reason I
spend some time at Santa Fe is that
turns out this can be useful in
understanding something very real so off
to Bali Island Bali where the bodies
have been growing rice in terraces since
at least the 11th century we know this
from royal inscriptions of the time
they've also governed themselves in
villages with a very ancient system of
democracy now democracynow.org
masted know more than a century in every
case but the Balinese have been we
believe managing their rice patties with
groups called su box which are groups of
men who share contiguous rice fields
with a democratic system since at least
the 12th century so it's an interesting
kind of experiment in democratic
governments so let me tell you a little
bit about rice patties they are
artificial ponds in which the fertility
of the water basically creates a kind of
an aquarium and the processes that go on
in the water help to grow the rice they
provide the nutrients
Cerie to grow the rice which is why we
find terraces in Valley that have been
producing two crops of rice every year
for centuries it's great trick and the
control of water is the key to making
that work the reason it works is that
volcanic rock is rich in mineral
nutrients let's see I got my little
pointer here so those are just the
phosphate content of rocks in Indonesian
volcanoes and valleys somewhere down
there it's not actually one of the
highest but there's plenty of phosphate
in the rock and as the monsoon rains
fall on that boom Asia's rocket that
very light rock rich with these
nutrients they leached the mineral
nutrients which flows into the
irrigation systems and that's delivered
finally to the rice paddies so it's sort
of a continuous delivery system for
phosphate potassium the main nutrients
required by the rice nitrogen is fixed
by Izola which grows in the water so you
have a kind of a perpetual motion
machine but the challenge for the
Balinese to make this work is that
island of bali is a steep volcanic
island just south of the equator and as
those rivers as the rain falls on the
slopes of the volcanoes it slices
channels down the slopes of the
mountains creating these kinds of
fissures so the Balinese need to get the
water from the bottom of these ravines
up to the top of a hill some distance
downstream where they can grow rice
which means they have to build tunnels
to move the water down to the higher
slopes and we find inscriptions dated as
early as the 9th century that referred
to irrigation tunnels builders so
they've been at it for a long time and
they've honeycombed the island with
their tunnels and terraces by now so
that's pretty clear water can provide
nutrients but it can also less obviously
be used to control rice pests so rice is
vulnerable to a variety of things that
like to eat it besides humans insects
which either eat the rice directly or
carry bacterial and viral diseases which
can spread through the rice rats and so
forth so there are lots of things that
like to eat the rice but by
synchronizing harvests over a
sufficiently large area
it's possible to deprive the pests of
their food in their habitat so here in
this slide you see after harvest they
flood the fields and there's nothing for
the pests to eat but that will only work
if all the farmers plant at the same
time generally they give themselves a
five-day window the fields there you can
see they're all it about the same stage
they're all at the same height so there
may be rice pests in the field now but
later on a few months from now after
those fields are harvested and flooded
nothing for the pests to eat the success
of this system depends upon getting a
large enough area fallow at the same
time because the pests can move so if if
you get a kind of a patchwork system if
one field is followed but the other
still has rice the pests can just move
around or be blown by the wind so the
success of this plan success of this
method for controlling the pests depends
upon getting the right scale of
coordination to deprive the pests of
their habitat which depends upon their
dispersal characteristics okay so that's
the basic dynamics the way the Balinese
organize this is through this thing
called a soo bahk so a sumac is consists
of all of the farmers who share water
from a single source like a spring or a
an irrigation canal and in the picture
what I'm trying to show you here is a
tunnel excuse me there's a temple where
they will gather to make their decisions
and then there's the the the rice
terraces which are managed by the
farmers who maintain that water temple
interestingly in the meetings which the
farmers have within their water temples
they set aside the rules of caste the
reason that's important is that caste is
very important otherwise in voluntee
society they're divided into the
aversion of the Hindu caste system but
they take it very seriously so when you
speak Balinese you have to first
determine what is the relative caste of
the person you're talking to and then
you use a different register depending
upon whether you're the person you're
addressing is of higher or lower caste
than you so a lot of this hierarchical
structure is built in even to their
language but when the farmers get
together to hold a meeting and talk
about the management of their rice
terraces all that is set aside you have
to speak to
to your peers to your fellow farmers and
middle high register Balinese or else in
the colloquial informal language that
you use within your own family if you
start using trumping people with high
language then you can be fine and it's
very much round upon so that is part of
what makes this democratic system work
all right so that's the sort of basic
subak and what's interesting is that
these sumachs then form a hierarchical
structure which sort of works from the
bottom up
so here we have the water temple network
sumachs
a and B these are two sumachs there's
the temple but they both share water
from this canal which comes from that
Dam
so they belong to this temple here and
from time to time once a year they'll
send a delegation up to their neighbors
up here and try to coordinate their
irrigation schedule because the timing
of the water released from this system
is going to clearly impact how much
water is available for their downstream
neighbors so in this way they sort of
build up from the bottom a hierarchical
structure of relationships among the
sooo box using the water temples so the
temples form a kind of network at the
summit of the network there is a crater
lake more or less near the real center
of Bali there's a lake which the
Balinese describe as a sacred mandala of
waters so they imagine that Bali is
surrounded by a salt sea but in the
center of the island at the highest
point there's there's a lake which is
full of life-giving freshwater in the
lake there dwells a goddess and it she
has the power to bestow this blessing of
water that makes things grow and also
washes away pollution down the flanks of
her volcano so water actually belongs to
the goddess and her temple is the
supreme water temple of the island she
chooses priests by inhabiting the voice
of a group of priests who how do you say
when when when in when a priest dies
then other priests will go into trance
they believe that they are possessed by
the voice of the goddess or some other
deity who is connected to her retinue
who then speaks the name of the child to
replay
that priest so in this way there's a
continuity somewhat like the tibetan
idea anyway these priests are live up
there in the village of banter by the
lake they collect holy water from the
points around the lake and the farmers
come up to collect that holy water is a
token of the blessings of the goddess of
light the Balinese call their religion
agama Teta the religion of water each
village temple controls the water that
flows into nearby rice terraces regional
water temples control the flow into
larger areas high up on the volcano
Mount Batur
there is an enormous crater lake the
Balinese believe the lake is the home of
the goddess of the waters davidann oh
who makes the waters flow into the
rivers and irrigation canals the supreme
water temple of bali sits on the rim of
the crater overlooking the lake once a
year priests give holy water from the
lake to the farmers as a blessing from
the goddess first priests ascend the
crater to collect drops of water from
the steam of the active volcano then the
priests prepare the holy water for the
farmers a temple scribe writes letters
on palm leaves inviting farmers to the
temple delegations from over 200
villages journey up the mountain to
bring offerings to the goddess
[Music]
at the supreme water temple the gamelan
orchestra plays in honor of the goddess
and the worshipers temple priests give
us sujeong a bamboo container filled
with holy water to each village delegate
the delegations then carry the holy
water to their regional temples here the
water from the goddess is mixed with
more holy water adding the blessings of
local gods and goddesses each delegate
receives a sujeong of this water to take
back to his village at the village
temples local farmers receive a blessing
for themselves and their fields a few
drops of holy water are sprinkled on
every field this ritual symbolizes the
sharing of water that forms a
coordinated system of irrigation in Bali
working together in this way the
Balinese have maintained the ecology of
their rice terraces for over a thousand
years
[Music]
sorry ok so um so it's a rather idyllic
system but there is a hidden problem
because in each case the downstream
shoebox are at the mercy of their
upstream neighbors for water the guys
upstream in any irrigation system have
their hand on this so they control the
water the question then is why do they
release the water needed for their
downstream neighbors because the
downstream neighbors can never give the
water back so why doesn't this lead to a
tragedy of the Commons as it so often
has in other irrigation systems we won't
talk about the World Bank yet so what's
different what's different about Bali
what makes it work ok well we built a
very John Miller at the Santa Fe
Institute came up with this very simple
formulation from game theory that
suggested an answer to that question so
imagine we have two farmers upstream and
downstream and they have a choice as to
whether they want to synchronize their
irrigation system or not planting or not
so if the upstream farmer is willing to
give up some water
they both plant at the same time then
the downstream farmer is happy and he
gets his water if on the other hand and
and the consequence then is they have a
coordinated fallow period they both
harvest at the same time and that can
help bring the pests under control
because the pests don't move upstream to
eat the upstream farmers field suppose
on the other hand they don't synchronize
so the upstream guy gets to keep more of
the water but on the other hand the
pests can come and attack his field so
it looks as though pests can give
leverage to the downstream farmer if the
farmers are thinking about pests in the
context of this water allocation problem
so we wondered if that very simple
formulation had anything to do with the
farmer the way the farmers actually
think about this thing so we asked them
we asked 150 farmers in 10 su box which
is worse
pests or water damage water shortage so
here the results the upstream guys
are worried about pests and the
downstream guys are worried about water
okay and that seemed to be true in each
of these ten subak so there is the
makings of a bargain turns out our
economist was right you can also look at
this at the next scale in six cases we
had an upstream downstream pair upstream
subak downstream subak so in this case
the agent is not an individual farmer
but a whole soo bahk well in that case
the pattern is even clearer the upstream
soo bahk is worried about pests and the
downstream sioux box in these six cases
are worried about water so that looked
as though we're actually to my surprise
that this actually worked out so well
they think about a lot of things but
this this seem to be present in the mind
of the farmers and helps to explain why
the upstream guys are in fact willing to
engage in these bargains with the
downstream farmers however this
two-player game is unrealistic because
in fact dozens and dozens of Sioux box
effect one another the irrigation
systems are highly interdependent there
are lots of little su box
dozens of Weir's and they're
interconnected so the real question is
how do they get it right not at the
scale of two players but at the scale of
in the case that we studied a hundred
and seventy two su box along two rivers
so I worked with the systems ecologist
Jim Cramer who suggested that we build a
simulation model and see how this might
work and at that point I just come back
from spending about a year studying one
soo bahk so when he said we should scale
up to one hundred and seventy two I was
impressed but anyway we did it so here's
a map these are two rivers the little
squares if you can see them are meant to
be the Sioux box the little kind of
Christmas tree things are meant to be
water temples and the stippled lines are
the boundaries of catchment areas for
the rivers so bear with me this is
pretty clear what happens in this in
this simulation is at the beginning of
the year
each of these hundred and seventy-two
Sioux box the village sized irrigation
systems chooses a cropping pattern what
are they going to plant so it might be
plant rice in January and August for
example then we simulate the flow of
rain the rain gets into the groundwater
the irrigation systems the rice grows
and the pests eat some of the rice we
simulate all of those processes and then
at the end of the year we calculate the
harvest yields for each of the SU box
okay so having done this they we then
vary the scale at which they coordinate
from everybody does the same thing to
everyone does something different to
water temple scale we can actually
identify what kinds of clusters of SU
box follow coordinated patterns based
upon the traditional water temple system
and to know one's real surprise it
turned out that the water temple
networks optimize the trade-off between
tests and water they get it about right
get enough water to each cluster of SU
box and at the same time minimize the
pest pest damage so that worked I mean
in other words we could week one can see
that this water temples play a useful
role in finding the appropriate scale of
coordination to optimize those two
opposing constraints so I gave a talk
much like this I think it was eight
years ago at the Santa Fe Institute and
at the end of my talk a researcher named
Walter Fontana asked me a question he
said this that's very interesting but
it's really not surprising after all the
farmers have had centuries to get the
scale right
tell me did someone have to design this
system was it organized the garages have
to work it out or could it have self
organized and at that time I didn't know
what he meant by that and he said well
do you have to does someone have to
impose this structure or could the
interactions between the sumachs lead to
this kind of a solution to the formation
of a network so that seemed like an
interesting question and a solution was
the solution we tried immediately was to
just tweak our little model a little bit
turn it into what's called a hill
climber to see if the water tiful
networks might pop out on their own so
the way that works is start the same
simulation but left the computer
randomly choose cropping patterns for
all hundred and seventy-two subak so
each of the little icons upward triangle
downward triangle they simply mean a
random choice of cropping patterns so a
downward triangle might mean plant rice
in October and I'm gonna March something
like that
so we're randomizing the conditions of
water which will affect the dynamics of
water flow
rice growth and pest dynamics so then we
run the thing for a year and at the end
of the year
each soo bahk compares its harvest with
its four closest neighbors so the little
it kind of got bored writing little
circles there but the little little
circles are supposed to suggest these
are the comparison groups so the end of
the year I look around and see if any of
my neighbors had a better rice harvest
and I did if so I copy their cropping
pattern if I did best then I stick with
my cropping pattern so that reinitialize
is the simulation and we run it again
jim cramer my colleague thought this
thing would yield it would produce chaos
at the model they'd keep flipping back
and forth as they tried first one
pattern to get in or the other but we
decided we run it anyway and here's what
we saw so here's a year one of a
simulation this is the random choice of
cropping pattern selected by the
computer
the average harvest is pretty miserable
it's about five tons per hectare because
there's lots of pest damage and lots of
water shortages ten years later
synchronize patches which you may or may
not be able to see have appeared so this
groups doing one thing in that group is
doing the same thing and the harvest
yields have nearly doubled
they walked their way to a solution and
that solution looks very much like the
water temple patterns in fact it's
almost identical and as we repeated
these simulations we found that it's
almost impossible not to grow a water
temple system we vary the pest
constraint the pests are more virulent
than the fallow periods get larger if
the water is more of a problem than the
then the patches get smaller but no
matter what the constraints are a
network will form given this kind of
trade-off that will optimize the
conditions so as this goes on this also
had another kind of interesting
consequence here this here the yields
okay rice yields as time goes on in the
simulation that's the average
that's the highest as time goes on
you'll see that the average yield is
going up until it comes very close to
the highest yield that flags the
attention of any evolutionary biologist
because we think that one of the reasons
that people or animals disagree is
because of in
disparities and benefits but if
everybody's not only doing well but
doing equally well then there's no
reason to be jealous and in fact as we
ask the farmers to compare their own
harvests to those the average in their
Sue box you can't read that that says
well mine's the same and that says that
it's worse
so even farm even Balinese farmers you
know like to badmouth their harvest but
they can't get away with it in their
sooo box because in fact everybody does
equally well and they do very well so
that suggested a way in which this
system could have persisted over time
you could imagine an indeed from time to
time farmers decide to be renegades and
they don't plant according to the
schedule it's possible to opt out it's
possible for sumachs to become defunct
as we'll see presently but over time
nature punishes you if you drift away so
over time we can see a process in which
if not me then my grandchildren are very
likely to kind of drift back into this
pattern of organization because it is a
very successful one one more thing about
this Network idea because I think it's
interesting to say that the point is
that it it may be a very general
phenomenon we discovered in Bali but it
may be quite general here's Kay that's
the number of with apologies to Stuart
Coughlin the number of neighbors that we
check in these simulations so in the
model world no not Bali but in the model
world ok how many neighbors do I compare
my harvest with before I decide what to
do well that has an effect if you if you
look only at three neighbors then as
time goes on the number of sumachs that
change strategies that dance that that
flip back and forth stabilizes with
about one third of them never finding
the right optimal solution they keep
flipping back and forth these are the
guys who never decide what to do they
because there may be a solution but they
can't find it because they're not
looking far enough out you go to K
equals four
then they find a solution faster the
network appears faster and fewer of them
remain confused ok and as we look even
further then 13 you get down to almost
all than we can find a solution because
they can see it if on the other hand you
look not at your immediate neighbors but
somewhere else in the system for example
it at the experimental farms then you do
get chaos then what happens is everyone
keeps flipping back and forth
identifying you know anyone to imitating
the best farm in the entire landscape
but that loses the signal from the
immediate vicinity this is exploring
your own immediate neighbourhood and
optimizing conditions there so that may
be general anyway it always succeeds and
the search parameter is important
hope that's clear okay so there is a
complex adaptive systems explanation for
water temples does that mean that
they're really just a kind of a
mathematical device well I can't believe
that I'm an anthropologist so I want to
talk about I want to talk about ritual a
little bit so they devote a great deal
of time and wealth and attention to the
rituals that take place in the water
temples and remember that these temples
are places where democratic decisions
are made so why do they do that why is
it important well it's characteristic of
discourse of the Greeks of the Romans of
the Italians of the 13th century anybody
who's interested in making a Democratic
assembly work winds up talking about the
control of emotions and so that becomes
the central focus of balinese discourse
on how do you make communities how do
you cope with achieving consensual
management so Balinese cosmology and
I'll have to do this briefly but it I
hope you'll be interested it posits a
dualistic cosmos the idea is that the
inner world of the self contains
everything that also exists in the outer
world and there are 202 components by
the way of the inner world in the outer
world so given that presumption there
are two ways to think about it one is
the male way the purusa which actually
is the high Balinese word for penis so
male power comes through through this
comes to the self especially to males
through their clan and it derives from
the ancestor it's something you inherit
it's what gives Kings the power to rule
but pradhana in voluntee
they've modified a sense good idea it's
the female principle the female half of
this cosmology and it is collective and
transformative it's about growth it's
about fertility and it is the pradhana
ritual cycle that exists in the water
temple networks so here offerings in a
water
temple which relates simultaneously both
to the inner and the outer world
depicting them in perfect order is a
kind of an ideal relating to both worlds
at the same time so water temple rituals
are intended to tame the passions and to
create order it's a monthly meeting here
of soo bahk heads in which they are
which they must set aside lineage
competition and we have these rights of
equality and he's about to pour some
very nice Balinese wine to the heads of
the SU box who've gathered once a month
to make decisions about the rice
terraces but what they talk about mostly
is not ecology they talk about politics
okay
these rituals of equality blind these
elements of the inner world so that we
can control the outer world and here's
another quick video clip you can read
this right
so here's art of the instrumental ritual
the sharing of water water
these are offerings that grew in the
fields of a sumac they're now putting
them in the water that leads into that
sue Bacchus returning thanks to the gods
of that system but we wondered if
there's something more to it than this
simple giving of thanks here here are
offerings out of water temple
[Music]
each family brings one of these
offerings that's what grew in their
fields
neither mudras aligning manner wrote
they liken rice patties to jewels and
jewels an important concept in Balinese
ideas that a jewel is something which
symbolizes the mind but rice terraces
like these once they're flooded with the
moonlight shining on them look like
faceted jewels as a Tsubaki head told me
once but that order will fall apart in a
week if all the farmers don't
systematically manage the the terraces
to maintain that jewel like precision so
they say that the problem is really the
same problem that of creating a jewel
like rice terrace system but it
originates in the self rather than in
the in the mud
ok so I'll go quickly through this I've
kind of got interested in this but
quickly through so there's a drive for
university and coherence in which they
believe that the human microcosm is an
intermediate between sort of the
Platonic view of how the other world is
put together how the universe is put
together and it's reflected in the way
in which they symbolize life so when
you're born then they take the after
birth components they after birth and
align it in the household according to
the directional symbolism which also
relates to sounds and colors and letters
in other words they align you with the
macrocosm and at the end of your life
when you died then they cover you with a
shroud which also depicts that alignment
although it shows the progression of
changes that have occurred in your life
so there's a sudra and you can see there
lots of different components of his body
the Brahmin priest has a simpler diagram
because it's thought that he spent his
lifetime trying to simplify the inner
world and that's reflected in the
diagram that is drawn over his his body
all right so that's what I'm gonna tell
you about Balinese ritual because we
need to move along so in the 1970s
everything changed for excellent reasons
Indonesia at that time was also
importing rice and in Asia was poor they
needed to improve the agricultural
productivity the Asian Development Bank
funded the Green Revolution and a new
era of agricultural expansion of
agricultural management began in Bali as
elsewhere in many part
to the world certainly in Indonesia but
it had unintended consequences so the
basic ingredient was something they
called a technology packet they
literally bucket technology in Balinese
which consisted of new rice varieties
spread to grow rapidly and to take up
chemical fertilizers effectively plus
those fertilizers plus organic chloride
pesticides and the farmers were urged to
plant rice as often as possible and set
aside the water temples the planters of
this system said it's perfectly fine to
continue to have your lovely rituals in
the water temples but don't think this
is a practical management system so this
system which develop was developed the
rice Institute the Philippines was moved
to Indonesia but within a few years
there were unexpected problems which you
can probably anticipate the line was
miracle rice has produced miracle pests
if indeed all of the farmers plant at
different times it's like running our
simulation model backwards disrupting
the pattern of coordination until you
wind up with the patchy structure in
which the pest can migrate from one
field to the others just like the
simulation model that's precisely what
happened so the first variety of rice
that they tried this with which was
named ir8 proved vulnerable to an insect
called the brown plant hopper 2 million
tons lost 77 so the the agronomist and
geneticists bred up a new variety of
rice which was resistant to the plant
hoppers but it proved to be vulnerable
to rice to grow disease that explosion
began a few years later so they came up
with a new variety IR 50 which was
resistant to tung grow but not so good
with rice blast and Hill meanthis Boreum
you see where this is going
so as time goes on and they the farmers
were were required to put on heavier and
heavier doses of pesticides until
finally by the 80s they were flying the
island spraying the fields and meanwhile
the Extension agents are reporting back
to it orders chaos in the irrigation
systems so we began to complain about
this the reason I've got involved with
the ecological modeling was really to
convince the Asian bank that the temples
had a practical function and they the
director was not happy with this in 1984
but we were happening eight years later
they sent teams we talked to them and in
the end of the
Asian Development Bank agreed with us
that the substitution of the
high-technology and bureaucratic
solution was counterproductive and in
fact they became converts to the water
temple system so that's a happy story
the planners have now dropped opposition
to the water temples in fact they'd like
to teach about them they show our movie
however the farmers are still urged to
buy these technology packets of
fertilizer and that's a problem because
as you've already learned the volcanic
rock is rich with nutrients so here's a
test that we did adding phosphate
fertilizer in six different fields six
uh box from zero phosphate to the
recommended dosage of 100 kilograms per
hectare has no effect on yields it's
just wasted because the phosphate is
already present in large concentration
that's the government's understood well
they allowed the water temples to regain
control but the Green Revolution still
lingers to this day
farmers add chemical fertilizer to this
ancient self-sustaining system for the
last thirty years
the farmers have been borrowing money
from the village cooperatives to buy
fertilizer that they don't need applying
it to the fields washes out of the
fields immediately flows back into the
rivers and down to the sea
[Applause]
this little stream is pulling right out
of those rice paddies up there and as it
comes down it's of course carrying all
the mineral nutrients from the volcanic
soil plus all that fertilizer weed all
the fertilizer that wasn't needed by the
farms and it's just washing down so by
the time it gets here to see it's like a
thin nutrient soup and so the effect is
you grow simple organisms like algae the
algae that you see growing along the
rocks there and that's what we find
offshore just blanketing the coral reefs
and we only find it in places like this
where you've got that kind of
agricultural drainage the rest of the
island if there's no River carrying
fertilizer then the reefs are fine but
out there the reefs and early judge
[Music]
Stephen Lansing and his colleagues are
gathering samples from reefs around Bali
trying to understand the complex web we
humans are part of they hope to help
Bali in its return to harmony
that's David Suzuki so problem is all
these nutrients flowing into the reefs
and coral reef are adapted to low
nutrient level so that's not a good
thing there's Jim Cramer taking samples
as one of the little streams emerges
into the into the field one more little
clip this is dick Murphy you may be here
tonight talking about tabular or table
coral these Acropora tablecloth some of
them the diameter of this boat and
they're in perfect health whereas on the
mainland we also saw some pretty large
corals but most of the large ones were
dead and so that tells us that in the
past the conditions were such the reef
was healthy thing and those big corals
lived long enough to really grow to a
substantial size but they're not alive
now so some things change so our
conclusions are the technology packets
of fertilizer were mostly superfluous I
have a Balinese student who's just got
his PhD sort of proving that by taking
measurements along a river for over a
year the excess phosphate in and the
excess phosphates not good for the
terrestrial ecology and the excess
nitrogen grows the algae that destroys
the coral and we can see that through
looking at stable nitrogen isotope
differences you can actually get the
signature of the kind of nitrogen that
is growing the algae does it come from
sea or does it come from the technology
packet so it's really a very foolish
mistake so why did we all why did we
miss all of this why did we miss all
this well I think the answer is if we
think about what are the elements of a
this complex adaptive system that I've
been talking about its water temples
which look like a religious system to us
that's what we thought they were
they're festivals that are held in those
temples here we see it a priest from the
from the master water temple and he's
carrying a little silver Cup in which
he's got holy water from the lake from
the goddess of the lake that if he were
to stumble upon this temple festival and
you see a guy in white with his little
silver cup sprinkling water on on
offerings you're not likely to be
thinking about control mechanism that's
right
synchronized cropping and that's maybe a
more obvious cue but took something to
pick it up I guess
and then the structure of the
connections between the water temples
through the holy water which goes from
the lakes to the canals to the fields
that really is the structure and then
finally there's this dimension of the
control of emotions the cosmological
order that allows the farmers to cope
with the jealousies and disagreements
that are common to everyone including
Balinese farmers so not an obvious
system if you wanted to look at the
connections between two sumachs in the
hierarchy you need to be there on the
right day when a few old men in white
clothes go up and collect some cups of
holy water to bring down to the fields
of their own subak downstream so I gave
this this talk at the University of
Michigan a few years ago and I at that
point I was ending it by saying and is
this only in value know where the
complexity dynamics really should be
characteristic not only of Bali but they
should be common if we're right I mean
the the trade-off between pests and
water for example generates a network
structure but if the farmers were
growing roses and trying to control
aphids you should still get some kind of
dynamic so I posed that question and
Lisa Curran who's a tropical forest
ecologist who spent well she's younger
than I am not a slum in Borneo anyway
said I have a we got a talk so I'm gonna
tell you a little bit about Lisa's
research on the forests of Borneo so see
so Lisa has studied the dipteryx those
are the tropical hardwoods of which
there are 12 general and about 470
species she is the real expert when she
can identify from the seeds and the
fruits and the nuts you know which kind
of dr. carp it is but in this in the
time that she studied them most of them
in Borneo
disappeared most of them are gone now
it's a tragic story so why did our
forestry planning go so far wrong more
5-year plans
well it's connected partly to as Lisa
found El Nino the El Nino Southern
Oscillation the weather pattern which
circulates across the Pacific which you
heard about we knew that enzo is it's
called the hell Nino cycle changes
weather patterns right from the
Galapagos it sort of takes the the
weather from the Galapagos in Borneo
cycling back in a several year cycle but
what we didn't know that Lisa helped
clarify is that these trees the Diptera
carps use ENSO as a signal and what the
signal does is to tell them to have a
mast a mast means drop your fruit it
means reproduce if you're a tree so
dropping the fruits and seeds that
happens for the for the dipteryx only
during the El Nino years so it's just a
kind of a trigger signal um
we're supposed to get a new slide here
Oh
so here the here you have if you can see
that these are the El Nino years and
these are the fruits patiently collected
by and Lisa and her and her team then
the density of seeds dropped in the
forest so you can see it exactly tracks
those El Nino years right so that now
you see what Lisa wanted to talk about
the water temples on many species
because this is a tremendous pulse of
food that arrives only in El Nino years
then the seed predators which means lots
of birds and mammals the bearded pigs
the largest migrations of mammals
outside of Africa occurring out in are
used to occur in Borneo and El Nino
years when the bearded pigs would have
their babies these are great big animals
so also the birds so all these creatures
would have they they would they will
have adapted an interesting evolutionary
dynamics they will have adapted to cycle
their reproductive activity for the
dipped or carp map masked which then
creates the kind of a master clock it's
kind of a clock in the heart of Borneo
as far as we know this does not exist in
other tropical forests and
Africa or Amazon but then again we
haven't really looked very much lease
has begun to work in Borneo we know so
little about these things but the point
I want to make here is it's very much
like the water temples this is
synchronized fallow controlling the
Predators right the trees are doing
pretty much what the farmers are doing
except in this case the trees are
extending their fallow period over the
whole island you know that's huge
regions she's been working with NASA to
see how large is the synchronisation of
fruiting of mass tting in the Diptera
carps and its enormous as far as we can
see in Borneo so that's what pulses food
availability and keeps down the sea
bration it makes it possible for the
dipped or carps to reproduce because it
provides so much food that the seed
predators can't eat it all but the plans
for forest reserves the 5-year plans
were based on the resident seed
predators rather than the pulses the
large numbers that occurred during the
El Nino years Solis has done experiments
showing that the seedlings can suffer 99
or 100 percent mortality during the El
Nino years the rest of the time they
would be fine and therefore the dipped
or carps cannot reproduce so here you
have not in 2002 from Lisa's science
article one of her science articles the
logged areas yellow is the logged areas
and the little green patches are what's
left of the dipped our carbs there's not
enough trees left for the mast so
there's been a reversal in so now
triggers not the regeneration of the
forest but fires because the
microclimate is gone it's no longer wet
the trees have been cleared and not only
will the forest burn but actually the
peat swamp will also burn leases in
Borneo now working on that problem and
that turns out to be a lot of carbon
emission okay you lose the trees so the
trees are no longer no longer fixing
carbon then we have forest fires in the
El Nino dry years and now also peat
fires so we're talking about 0.8 billion
metric tons of carbon per year and the
Kyoto global target for reduction was
0.5 so it's huge
we're not you know not to mention the
loss of biodiversity
okay so we're moving along here two
examples then of complex adaptive
systems one in Borneo one in Bali
different dynamics but in some way maybe
some in some ways similar dynamics
bottom-up control emergent networks that
worked and then we're disrupted but I
want to end with another way of thinking
about this
not just the complexity perspective but
of balinese perspective so maybe another
way to think about the long now
so the Balinese have very different
ideas about time and here is a simple
little board which is the Balinese
called a new COO or a tika a calendar
and it looks like if you could see it
clearly which you can't but it's it's
like a matrix it's 30 well is it columns
and seven rows well actually it's nine
one on top and bottom
funny-looking a little thing little
wooden board let me explain what it is
so think about what our kind of calendar
does we have an indo-european in the
indo-european languages we speak of time
in a linear fashion we think of time as
a moving moment right the past is behind
us futures in front of us and the
present is this moment right now in
between the two that's how we tell time
and that's actually the arrow of time so
to speak is someone that is embedded in
our language because we make order of
things by talking about tense right when
did things happen it's obligatory to
speak in English or French or whatever
in terms of past present future tense
that's how we talk about things
Balinese language and in the Indo excuse
me the Austronesian languages don't have
tenses they create sense in a different
way and they have a very interesting way
of calculating time I think it's the
world's most complex or Italy right the
most complete way of thinking about time
and it's in terms of multiple concurrent
cycles so time as dense so let me just
quickly walk you through what those
calendars do and this will just be quick
okay so first of all they have a lunar
calendar and we kind of have a lunar
calendar right from the Romans but they
are
heard about it so they give you they
count 15 days of the waxing moon 15 days
of the waning moon but then they
subtract a day every 63 days and since
the lunar cycle is 29 days 12 hours and
44 minutes that keeps their lunar
calendar accurate okay so they're
actually keeping track of lunar time in
that way they also borrowed from India
via Shaka calendar which is a loony
solar calendar which keeps accurate
track of the solar year by interspersing
into a calorie lunar months so these
months are of different duration and you
stick them in at an interval of 2 or 3
years so as to keep so as to get it
right and keep accurate track of the
solar calendar
so the Asaka calendar began in 79 AD and
that's what they use and then finally
they have this cuckoo so what's the oku
it's 10 concurrent weeks and I hope I
can explain this through so we have the
seven-day week right Monday Tuesday
Wednesday Thursday Friday
well Balinese also have a three-day week
so the three-day week is possible Tonka
John so today is Posada tomorrow's
Patong tomorrow's kajang and it just
recycles right it is concurrent with the
Monday Tuesday Wednesday week there's
also a two-day week so today's Munga
tomorrow is the putt so that's also
cycling along there's even a 1-day week
so the one-day week there's only one day
long and definitely today is luan all
right yeah so all of this is cycling and
I didn't even got room to put on my
little PowerPoint the ten nine and eight
day weeks all these concurrent all these
going constantly at the same time so
time becomes dense and here is now an
attempt this is what the Balinese are
now compelled to do to try to plot all
that information on a Western calendar
so this is uh yeah it's a this is gonna
be the March calendar because they also
have to keep track of our systems so in
one of these little boxes you're gonna
have the information to tell you what
what week what lunar day is it in lunar
calendar what day is in the solar
calendar and what day is it in all of
these 10 concurrent weeks most people
can keep track of a lot of this net so
it just gives you some clues like and
you can't read it anyway there's going
to go that's the 4th day of the four-day
week so all of that
is going on all right so what do we make
of that well it suggests that time is
dense it suggests that the way to think
about it is in terms of patterns that
emerge from interlocking cycles and
that's how you schedule water tipple
rights is by those multiple cycles you
know water cycles that the duration of
the calendar is 210 days and so that
turns out to be the most important cycle
on the reason that little board has 210
days on it rather you know we many ways
you could do the group 200 days is the
growth cycle of old Balinese rice so the
master calendar is the rice calendar
cycle but within it you keep track of
many other things so for example most of
the time nobody cares what day as data
is on the eight-day week but when your
child is born the day of its birth on
the eight-day week gives you a clue as
to who it is who's been reincarnated
into your family from the mother's
mother's side father's father's side so
human cycles are there and the notion is
that there you know that you couldn't
reach the end of this there's so many
different cycles going on they're
interlocking so many ways all we as
humans can do is keep track with the
most important ones so the three-day
week is the market week the market
happens in one village and one day the
next village the next the third village
the third day and then comes back again
so that has nice advantages instead of
the poor old retailers who have to sit
in their shops from 9:00 to 5:00 every
day they're there every three days right
so you they triple their market size and
there's lots of and is less than just
sort of sitting and being the reason it
works is we have inscriptions from a
thousand years ago that the market cycle
never changes if if this is the village
and the market is owned a cut young the
day one of the three-day week it will
never change so it's entirely
predictable so interesting ways to use
time to create order and maybe save
people some time they also use the
metaphor of music Judith Becker years
ago a linguist wrote a great thing
called time and tune in Java showing
that you can also this is how you think
about music music is composed of
multiple interlocking cycles that's how
gamelan music is put together something
like fugues and so order appears if the
cycles are integrated well
and it doesn't of course if they're not
well integrated so music and time are
clearly metaphors for one another that
little image is from a Balinese
traditional manuscript called proc
khenpo which tries to relate cycles of
music and tone with letters and colors
and gods and emotions and all those
things so it's one great package and I'm
at the end here because we began with
John Holland's work on complex systems
and his notion of what a complex
adaptive system is but his more recent
book is called hidden order so I want to
suggest to you that there is an
interesting hidden order here it's taken
me years as an anthropologist to begin
to you know to see that these little
funny little boards and things actually
can hold very profound ideas and I want
to suggest to you seriously if you're
thinking about time that this is a way
to think about time that may be worth
considering because this is this is the
time that ecologists think about really
it's not the physics of time it's the
ecological view of time as having many
cycles but if we don't think about those
things I think what I've shown you is a
kind of a litany of Horrors we've made
colossal mistakes and that my colleagues
the people who the people I work with in
Indonesia are very worried people I mean
when I what I've seen in lifetime what
Lisa's seen in hers and you know these
stories could be multiplied there aren't
very many people trying to study these
systems lisa is now dividing your time
between Borneo and and the Amazon
because there's still a lot left of the
Amazon we're just beginning to twig to
the most basic you know patterns
complexity is giving us some clues
simple clues about what to look for but
in the meantime these systems are
collapsing you know right before us and
I'm sorry to say people like us we're
the ones who are responsible for many of
these changes I mean these the we if
we're going to continue to to push
forward in what one geologist calls the
Anthropocene right this new geological
epoch in which human beings take control
of the planet we need to get smart fast
so that's my story I need to acknowledge
my many collaborators this is the many
years of work
and I think I'll just list them there
rather than try to read all their names
thank you very much
[Music]
that's awesome Steven thank you a couple
of questions are some coming up here
still I'm curious how the does any of
this play out looking at the pictures of
the terraces they're extraordinarily
refined artifacts people manage the
maintenance of that how do you you know
that they're most how do you keep free
riders and people shirking their work
and so on is that dealt with by the shoe
box or by one that is dumped with the C
box and I you know I had I haven't you
need to read my book you get the whole
story it's kind of a long story but that
is their central problem they know how
to build those terraces that's not the
problem the problem is how do you indeed
get people to keep it up because this
system can fall apart so easily and so
they devote a great deal of thought and
attention to to that and partly it is a
ritual system you know part of it is
overt but but and how do you cope with
people who are Free Riders you can say
in the end that though that the nature
will punish them and in the next you
know a generation or two it'll all come
right but in the meantime things can
fall apart sumachs fail we studied over
a period of three years I'm giving you a
long answer but it's critical to so or
created three years I had two teams of
volunteers research who's studying a one
must jetty which means one collection of
14 sous box that's a lot of soo bahk so
we couldn't study them all the time so
what we did is to have one group that
was measuring kind of field conditions
how much rice is growing what are the
nutrient components are the SU box
actually really planning at the same
time or not the other group went to the
meetings did five successive surveys ask
people do you trust your sumac leader
what happens when things go bad you know
we kind of went through all that and
what we found was three of those sumachs
actually failed during the time that we
studied them but all but one was able to
put itself back together again so it's a
very precarious kind of it's easy for
things to fall apart so that's why
there's this tremendous emphasis I think
on the ritual system which encourages
people to think we'll just end on this
you know the ritual system says its
emphasizes that the order within me can
also be depicted as an order of our
group if we were a soo bahk all of us
together would would be performing
rituals with with offerings which would
symbolize the kind of powers of order
that come together from
each of us and they do that you've seen
in some of my pictures the performance
of those rituals I think is crucial to
keeping people in the frame of mind that
they can this can actually work a couple
questions from Kevin Kelly all he's
going through everybody else's questions
he notes that farmers are notoriously
thrifty but there's actually no benefit
from these technology packets from the
fertilizer why would they keep on
putting scarce money into that was okay
that's a great question for a while it
was illegal to plant the farmers were
told it was their patriotic duty and and
what happens is the AG the AG extension
people appear with the technology
packets they say they just push it off
the truck here we are in your village
superior technology packets you don't
have to pay us now we're just gonna
deduct the cost of these inputs when we
buy your rice from you so there wasn't
much choice about it for a while it was
even illegal not to not to follow the
prescription and nobody was measuring
you could at first you know you need for
high yielding rice you need more
nitrogen fertilizer than the natural
system provides once you start using the
art the chemical fertilizers so
fertility declines so pretty soon you
actually do need this stuff you just
don't need as much you donate any
potassium at all but but who knows
because it's several different inputs
that they're putting on their fields and
who knows which one is making an effect
so given time they could they probably
own a totally figure this out but we can
help you know by using a colorimetry and
actually testing great okay second
question from Kevin rice harrassing is
common in China Philippines Nepal and
throughout Asia which Kevin just walked
all over are there parallels with Bali
and those very similar systems I keep
hoping to have a student who will help
figure that out I think that there must
be but I don't actually know I don't you
haven't got any all right from Watson
where are you waving his hand right
there
what other complex adaptive systems that
you have been exposed to what other
complex adaptive system you've been
exposed to is most similar to that of
the irrigation system in Bali I guess in
addition to Borneo
you see other systems like this they
have this I mean for example the
synchronized pulse of pester feeding and
so on
well you okay Conal you couldn't make an
argument that that's what Adam Smith was
writing about that's what the Mart the
market does something like this right
buyers and sellers form a network and if
everybody is joined in that network that
simple Network then the idea that basis
of microeconomics right is that
everybody's satisfaction is maximized
and the goods all get moved around in
the right way and all is very well that
however is very different from them so
that's kind of a complex it's a system
with a very simple structure you just
need to connect buyers and sellers
voluntee systems sort of like that what
happens is that if you connect up the
the farmers and they interact but not
only with each other also with nature
and nature rewards the more punishes
them for what they do then you get this
scent you also get an optimization
solution however the difference is the
farmers can't act completely selfishly
they have to cooperate or it doesn't
work so you get so and it's a little
more complicated structure because it
has to take into account the ecological
dynamics rather than just the social
interactions well speaking of social
interactions question from Howard how
does the shoe pack system coke with cope
with eco maniacs and sociopaths
well there's one sumac head who who was
kind of a thief and people would
complain that that others were stealing
water and what was he gonna do about it
and he would say go ahead what do I care
so this system at that point fell apart
and the okay this will take a minute to
explain maybe it's interesting so so
bonnie is a very tolerant of misbehavior
because they believe in karma and they
believe that if you misbehave you will
reap the rewards of or rather the the
consequences of what you do so to
challenge you in a rice village and your
grandparents lived in the same village
you've been there forever it's a small
closed community people know each other
picking fights is really something you
you want to be very careful about so
they're very patient about it um but in
the case of that guy some urine during
the course of the time of our study he
atoned for his sins resigned as subak
head and the Subic was able to
reconstitute itself so there is
something about the kind of tacit social
pressure that can that that they have
great faith in more faith than I would
have had a question I have is where
continuity plays into this even the
model ear and showed that basically the
system took shape in ten years do you
think it took shape in ten years a
thousand years ago no well I think we
actually did some archaeology and on
what I think happened is people started
experimenting with small-scale
irrigation systems and the first on the
coast and then in the mountains and they
sort of grew and there came a time when
you'd have as you'd have several sumachs
along an irrigation line and they'd have
to begin to cooperate and it grew
because they were able to use this
temple system you can compare it to Java
there's a whole chapter in my book about
Java where things didn't work out that
way because they had broad flat
irrigation systems Bali could easily not
have achieved this the level of
terracing that they have I think it's
it's because of the invention of water
temples that they were able to create
these they are able to extend the
terraces their their irrigation tunnels
that go on through kilometres you know
there can be a 10-kilometer system
winding its way underground and
above-ground and that for that to work
the guy at the end right ten kilometers
down has to believe that he's going to
get his water reliably or it's not worth
digging those tunnels so the question
really is a sociological one how can you
have enough trust so that these things
will work one more word on that so we I
took an archaeologist who'd work in the
Mayan for in Scarborough and we dug soil
cores in a very ancient water temple to
see how old we thought it was ancient
and then along the irrigation canal to
see if we could figure out how old it
was you know down to the end so five
meters down we found our best guess is
it's about an eight hundred year old
system so that means that it's been
around for a long time and the point is
the guy at the end has been able to
receive his water delivery through those
through that very long period of time
that's what's you know that's what's
kind of neat about it yeah
here's a question from Stephen Hill
who's where right there these technology
interventions seemed well-intentioned
but naive we are now entering an era of
cheap collaboration mediated by the
Internet
how can we benefit from the wisdom of
successful complex systems in creating
these collaborations
well my honest answer is we need to go
it's kind of kind of sympathetic with
Maynard Smith we need to go from simple
models of complexity to empirical cases
we've got some new tools now and we need
to apply them and see if things like
this might exist not exactly like this
but we should be a little more creative
in using some of the tools that the
physicists and mathematicians have given
us to see if they might exist in other
places that's what I think Arthur Young
has a question right here since as a
Caucasian you are a representative of
those who brought the Balinese the green
revolution which disrupted their ecology
why were you trusted what did your team
need to do I'm sure everybody trusts me
but it's not like that it's not about
Caucasians and in an Asians
it is about hierarchy I suppose but I'm
a professor and they respect professors
especially if they professors who speak
Balinese are likely to get a real
hearing and in fact they're too likely
to to put too much talking what I have
to say I love the readability these
questions by the way people this is
awesome
penmanship here Ken Wilson has a very
readable question are there so cycles of
expansion and contraction and the
proportion of land under cultivation or
other underlying cycles over El Nino and
generational effects does
self-regulation lead only to balance
constancy and are such cycles also
reflected in religious cultural ideas
you know the density of time you talk
about with all these different cycles
have we just heard about a few of them
tonight yeah I have to be cautious here
maybe we don't
archeologists move in packs lots of them
working
myah they were only a handful who work
in places like Bali so we don't really
know very much what we do know is that
there was a process of expansion of rice
cultivation but it's now actually
contracting because of the tourist
industry and the you know new land
development farmers it's become the
farmers own small patches of land it
takes a lot of labour to grow rice it's
not very economically productive so
there's a temptation to sell their rice
paddies particularly if if they can get
a lot of money for it along the roads
and hotels and once that process begins
in the sumachs can fall apart so if we
want to collect pests for example for
our ecological work we go down to what
used to be sue bucks around the towns
they're usually not sue bucks anymore
that land is very rapidly folding up and
and so there's actually a process of
contraction happening now although given
what's happened to the tourist industry
in Bali who knows I don't really know I
mean that may change because tourists
aren't going to bali anymore in such
numbers
there's tourism cycles and real estate
cycles also a good question from Sarah
it is fascinating that this works with a
monoculture crop is there any
application of this methodology that
would assist with the collapse of u.s.
Midwest monocultural farming I'm no
expert I mean here in California you
know we pour a lot of pesticides on
cotton crops and it I know only
anecdotally from talking to Davis
agronomist that something like this valu
system would control tests here but I'm
I don't want to go too far down
something of which I know very little
but the basic principles seem pretty
clear i I mean as I say it's water and
test in this case we could have we wrote
a paper a few years ago but that's a two
factor optimization you could be trying
to optimize three things at once and you
could still get network structures
emerging all right so in principle it
seems to me it's worth looking at that
question here's a question from Ray and
a common one you know what is genetic
modification going to bring to this kind
of game with the advent of genetically
modified seed stock is there a potential
for traditional planning cycles being
disrupted you must have had some of that
already with the Green Revolution rice
which was modified reserve all right it
was kind of an error in the first place
they thought well you can't have they
said traditional water temples this is
the
Bank talking in the 70s traditional
water temples are optimizing a system
based upon slow growing low yielding
rice and therefore they're not
appropriate for high yielding
agriculture the flying that is that the
temple structure is actually a flexible
system they make decisions all the time
about changing their cropping patterns
so they're perfectly competent at
growing new high yielding varieties of
rice they just make the appropriate
adjustments so there's nothing really
wedding into that what's happened
however is that the genetic most of the
Balinese native varieties are gone
they've simply been lost but they're
still in the mountain some that have
been preserved and happily I should tell
you this is sort of good news the
Indonesian government has decided that
they are going to in principle support
organic farming now in the future so we
have experiments going on with Balinese
in which they're trying trying to
quantify the effects of switching back
to organic farming and the use of native
varieties of rice and you can race them
then see how they do against each other
the question from the Jonathan is
Schechter out there are the Balinese
rituals actually useful in explaining
subak coordination or is it a purely
selfish model for each Siew back copies
it's high productivity neighbors isn't
that just as explanatory do you need all
this religion stuff no I mean it's sort
of there's the model world I think
here's what I want to say in the model
world my point is we can build a really
simple model that will grow water temple
structures and that's not what really
happened that's just a kind of a
mathematical proof of concept in the
real world I want to re-emphasize the
problem is getting people to agree to
coordinate to be to be cooperative at
levels that are basically unwell I don't
know unprecedent rare level of
cooperation is required to make this
system work otherwise the fact that you
have water temples wouldn't work the
farmers still have to cooperate and that
I think is the tough part
there's question from Chris tell us you
surf off of Bali given the state of the
coral reefs is there any cooperation
between the farmers and the fishermen
and this would be it you know sort of it
is that can the temple process include
them or is that just hopelessly two
different worlds
well the fisherman in Bali by and large
are not Balinese they're Booga knees
they belong to different groups they're
not many Balinese fishermen they don't
Oshin is that hasn't been their way of
life so there hasn't been much of that
however part of the that you saw on some
of this stuff on the diving there are
dive diving scuba diving has become an
important resource for the Balinese
economy so the scuba dive operators are
very keenly interested in trying to
preserve the coral reefs and our the
scuba divers reading your stuff we keep
trying we put you know some of this
we've been put on Balinese TV so but
takes time because you know this is
another question an anthropologist went
through in the 50s and 60s applied
anthropology and all of that is you know
an anthropologist goes in and sees some
pathologies in the system what is your
responsibility and what is the right
kind of action to take to try to fix
things you see going wrong as an
anthropologist well I am very alarmed I
mean I see between the four I see the
loss of the genetic diversity I see
that's you know I don't want to run this
in the ground but I mean we're made
catastrophic mistakes Borneo rainforests
are nearly gone and the length of time
I've been working in Indonesia the
richest oldest most diverse terrestrial
ecosystem on the planet most of the
coral reefs are vulnerable and we don't
know very much about them I mean that's
you know we when I say that this is
based upon minimal research we have not
prioritized this so it's all gonna be
over before we've even noticed we have
really set in if you think that the
alright I'm in touch with the scientific
community that looks at these problems
there are not many people working on
these problems and we are not at all
sanguine about what the results will be
so as an anthropologist I mean it's sort
of transcended anthropology to me I
mention it no yeah let me leave it at
that I'll go on too long George George
looks like can see honey right here
we're the Dutch influenced by the
Balinese water engineering systems or
the Balinese by the Dutch there was a
very interesting controversy when the
Dutch Dutch conquered volley in the late
19th century finished the conquest by
nineteen
at which point they put in controllers
they put in a colonial administrative
system and Bali was kind of the prized
assignment for a while in the 20s and
30s was the best place to be a colonial
officer in the whole the Indies and
they're very competent guys and some and
they got very interested in how the
melanie's irrigation systems work the
Balinese are very interested the Dutch
are really interested in irrigation
systems so there was a controversy that
has gone on and it's even continued in
anthropology about what was the extent
of royal control over urug Asian versus
how much of this was actually done from
the bottom up by the farmers I'm and I
should tell you that there is a German
and there's several anthropologists who
disagree with me Brigitta Hauser Shiblon
german anthropologist thinks that really
the master water temple was a royal
temple and if there was a royal role for
irrigation and that I've kind of missed
the that I've misunderstood this system
um I don't believe that but anyway um
but so so I'm tell you that this is not
the consensus view this is just it's
perfectly a German anthropology's a
confident anthropologist that she's not
an ecologist and she doesn't know
anything about the complexity that's
interesting so what's still mysterious
there for you and you go back to Bali
what still keeps you puzzled and if you
could bear down and do some more
research there what would you focus on
well right now there's a we were trying
to figure out a way to monitor to expand
from studying Balinese agriculture to
the other rice growing areas of
Indonesia because the problems that I've
described in Bali are there's a uniform
the technology packets they're
everywhere so somebody asked where do
those come from by the way what's the
source of the technology and agents have
from natural gas they produce a good
deal of their natural gas production
goes into urea into nitrogen fertilizer
which they sell at a roughly half the
world price to their own farmers that's
a lot of money and if our results are
correct most of that money is going down
the drain
okay so we feel a real sense of urgency
about getting on top of that however
because the government is now shifted to
supporting at least in principle a
change towards organic farming the
question now is how to implement
implement that so I think we're really
kind of an array
I'm working with volunteers there are
you know this is a good university in
Bollywood I own a university there
Kartini there a number of Balinese
agronomists people working on this
problem so that's kind of what we're
focused on right now that and then the
the forests that's what was the source
of the shift to or getting interest in
organic farming you know I I don't know
I mean we've been plugging away trying
to make this case but I don't want to
claim credit for it I don't really know
what led to this change in the in the
government policy and so it wasn't me
that's for sure but but well I should go
back find out cuz that's that would be
interesting is in a sense that's a
self-correction happening at yet another
level of the hierarchy yes and we know
did that come through the internet or
from people getting educated somewhere
besides Bali
well I think it's partly the cost of the
fertilizer this there because you know
they're losing a lot it's hundreds of
millions of dollars that are so we're on
forgone profits from their natural gas
okay say a little about when does your
book come out perfect toward April if
they tell me April well I'll send out a
summary to everybody on this I'll put a
link on Amazon to that but say just a
little what's in the book in addition to
what we saw tonight it's much you don't
hear about Borneo but it's very much
this story it's just it's essentially
the story I've told you tonight in a
little a little more coherent form that
was about the most coherent lecture and
thank you for it very much thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]